daily mail reports cnn says chris
cuomo's fate will be decided in the next
several days after text messages
revealed he wrote andrew's pest
rebuttals assault pest rebuttals and
used sources to dig dirt on accuser the
victim says system protects powerful men
from accountability newly released texts
show how cnn host chris cuomo helped
strategize his brother's response to
harassment allegations cnn told
dailymail.com the transcripts of cuomo's
interview with investigators in the
texts will be reviewed we will be having
a conversation and seeking additional
clarity about their significance as they
relate to cnn over the next several days
so maybe he won't be fired but we'll see
a march first message he sent to the
governor's chief aide melissa de rosa
included included a suggested written
response andrew cuomo should have used
the messages were released by the new
york attorney general's office monday
in one chris said his friend asked actor
alec baldwin to post a 14-minute video
rant on instagram in defense of his
disgraced governor brother grissetti
asked his friend to tell baldwin to stay
out of the scandal the texts also reveal
the television personality was
investigating one woman who accused the
ex-politician of trying to kiss her at a
wedding
derosa and cuomo would often send her
unsolicited advice which she often
ignored
all right cuomo
he's not a journalist he is a content
creator for cnn and i'm gonna make sure
i give proper credit where credit is due
this is danny and ryan long danny uh
polished chuck i'm probably not saying
your name wrong danny but they had this
funny bit on their podcast about how you
know it would just really irk the media
by calling all their journalists content
creators and ryan long is like the right
would roll with it and be like i guess
whatever and the left would just freak
out no we're journalists no no hold on
chris cuomo's not doing journalism here
he's directly intervening in a political
scandal using a media network to protect
his corrupt brother who assaulted women
who had killed the elderly and all of
this cnn helped cover up not a
journalist but he does make content so i
think it's fair to call cuomo a content
creator
and he was lying about it from the very
beginning of this scandal cnn said that
they were investigating ties between the
brother the governor and of course the
anchor and they're looking into it and
they're going to have a thorough
investigation and now we have the new
york state
attorney general release all these text
messages that implicate him i mean i'm
really surprised that cnn is not going
to give him a medal in excellency of of
lying and deception i mean cnn for
frick's sakes look at their lineup they
got lube and tubin they got they got the
they had the brain eating guy they got a
vanderbilt they got they got the guy who
talks about black holes swallowing
airplanes and now they have creepy como
i mean cnn is not a news organization
they are a smear merchant operation that
does the bidding and the pr of the super
powerful that wants to impose their will
or their willy on to the unsuspecting
innocent public and i am sick of these
people having carte blanche promotion by
all these big tech social media
companies sorry i had that lined up i'm
so
[Applause]
he's not but that's the most trusted
name in news they had people eating
brains on national television promoting
that see youtube's like that's great
that's awesome that's family-friendly
content that we got to push in the
algorithm meanwhile independent media
like my channel your channel we are
changed we get screwed over and of
course we get down ranked and you know
there's so many instances cnn even i i'm
a little biased here obviously cnn put a
false strike on one of my videos and
prevented me from doing live streams
when i had a live show because i played
a portion of the president's speech
which was during the state of the union
so they they rigged the algorithm in
many different ways but
regardless
chris como should be obviously fired
here but with the low
reputation that cnn has will he that's
the larger question that i think a lot
of people are asking them how long did
it take you to write all that luke that
was during the show you were doing the
introduction you're doing the
introduction i'm like
i could go on a roll here
the brain-eating guy yeah
they got creepy cuomo yeah who was black
following airbnb
oh man wow cnn's reputation could not be
worse you know i i had an idea i woke up
the other morning uh no i think it was
it this morning maybe um i i usually
wake up and then i just like i don't
know man i'm coming off a groggy weird
dream and i'm like vaguely remembering
what's going on i immediately pick up my
phone right when i wake up and i hit up
twitter and then the first thing i saw
was a tweet from brian stelter about the
omicron variant and then i was just like
yeah stelter variant i was like oh wait
a minute this is a good idea i was like
we should just call the name the
variants after cnn's lineup yeah and so
i was like i'm not going to call it
omicron i'm going to call it the lemon
variant because lemon's actually like a
regular word too and so we'll just name
all the variants after cnn hosts and i
call them content creators too because i
agree like
they're not journalists they just make
content and truth be told this is really
important
seriously we talk about cnn's ratings
being complete trash and in the gutter
and that's true but they do get a ton of
youtube video views because youtube
promotes them so cnn's lineup
they get i think they get like 100 to
200k in the key demo and like all
all together it's only like 400 so
they're well below the ratings of this
show and i'm not saying that to like
braggers i'm just pointing out like
they're irrelevant but they get the
youtube views
more than we do and we're on youtube so
they're just content creators that's all
they are but a lot of that is for forced
a lot of that is the algorithm literally
pushing them no matter who's online
usually the algorithm is curated for a
particular audience but you look up any
kind of news related event cnn is top up
up there so they have a huge advantage
over of course independent media when
they're causing real life harm
you know
cnn and other corporate media make the
argument that independent media is
causing harm to the general public by
lying and spreading misinformation well
number one look at exactly what cnn did
whether it's the hurricane katrina the
2008 bailouts whether it's the weapons
of mass destruction time and time again
they kept lying through their teeth that
led to real life consequences even on a
smaller micro level when we look at
chris como literally going after looking
up dirts using cnn's resources to go
after the accusers of his brother who's
governor of new york who's been accused
of doing really inappropriate stuff to
other female members of his staff family
friendly show we can't get really into
the details here a lot of it is also
vague but that that should be the least
thing that como should be in trouble for
a lot of the allegations are like when
he grabbed that woman by the neck and
like pulled her in and she's like
clearly freaked out then cuomo himself
put out a montage of him inappropriately
touching people to justify be okay it
was funny because he was like i'm i'm an
italian you know i touch everybody
here's a video of me doing it and you're
just like oh it's making it worse yeah
it's like all these videos of him like
grabbing faces of random people and i'm
like it doesn't make you innocent it
just makes you a bisexual assailant but
it wasn't just faces it wasn't just
people feeling uncomfortable it was also
people being touched in other private
areas it was also forcefully kissing
them and making them feel really
uncomfortable by making a lot of
innuendos and kind of demands and
of course you know
that thing is still nothing compared to
what he did to the state of new york
during of course the beginning of kovid
with his policy when it came to elderly
homes and the larger impact that he had
on the large number of people that died
as a consequence because of his direct
policies that killed people so that to
me should be the bigger controversy it
shouldn't be of of course you know a lot
of the pr stuff it shouldn't be a lot of
the lighter stuff because there is some
lighter stuff mixed in with some of the
heavier stuff but this shows a kind of
um
you know characterization of someone
who's above the law who who thinks that
they could do whatever they want who
routinely abuses people around them and
they think they could get away with it
because they're in a high position of
power that's the kind of kind of grease
ball thinking that should be called out
because it leads to of course on a lower
level people feeling uncomfortable on a
bigger level grandma being pushed in
with the latest coveted cases inside of
her nursing home because he thinks he
could get away with it and he has
andrew cuomo killed like 15 000 people
easily that's the numbers we know he hid
the numbers he lied about the numbers so
those numbers are probably a lot bigger
and the fact that he made that policy
the fact that he hid that policy is also
another big aspect here because he was
caught lying manipulating the data
manipulating the information the new
governor of new york came out and said
hey there's actually a lot more people
here that were caught up in this there's
actually a lot more people here that
were affected by this that we didn't
even know about and i mean when you get
to this kind of level of sociopathic
thinking this kind of level of making
these decisions that that impact people
so negatively this is absolutely nothing
but it still should be called out for
they still should be held accountable
for all the egregious actions that
they're doing it's because they hated
trump so much yes it was that trump sent
in the mercy a naval vessel and the
javits center had been opened for
emergency uh usage and the mercy i don't
believe was ever used maybe like one or
two beds something the javits was at 30
but cuomo was like eh let's not give
trump a win and so he put recovering
covered patients who are still
infectious into nursing homes and uh in
in pennsylvania where this is happening
too under governor tom wolf
it was the now um
admiral
yeah honorary admiral of uh whatever
biden's appointee for health services
rachel rachel levine right yeah yeah
took their parents out of a nursing home
just before the sick people were put in
yeah that shows
uh uh for knowledge yeah that they were
were going to be killing the elderly yep
they didn't care they knew they had
hospitals that were wide open in the
middle of central park that were just
put there there were field hospitals and
there was no one in them so why would
you do this kind of policy it absolutely
makes no sense at all and the fact that
he didn't go down for that the fact that
he went down for something else later
down the line shows you that there's
bigger things at hand here there's more
political manipulation here there's a
there's a bigger power structure that
probably did ensue between the como's
and another power structure there was
probably a bigger ask by the power
structure that como probably didn't want
to go along with but also with this
latest revelation this is another
another aspect to
talk about here because this was the new
york attorney general that released
these text messages and for people to
think that this is not political that
this is not done in a bigger power grab
is also i would say a little bit naive
since of course most new york politics
is extremely political extremely related
to criminal organizations criminal gangs
as well so i do believe that there's a
bigger power struggle here and they're
going after the como is bringing them
down because of something else that we
might not even know about personally
from my own opinion thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time